Democrats continue with their outrageous
rhetoric some extreme examples of just
how radical the left has become first
off an Illinois Democratic congressional
candidate under fire after comparing
President Trump to the mastermind of the
September 11th terror attacks on cast
ins campaign is now backtracking saying
his words were poorly chosen and he
regrets them meanwhile in Arizona
Democrat is threatening ice agents
congressman Ruben Gallego warning
government officials conducting
so-called illegal deportations that they
will not be safe from future punishment
when Trump is no longer president and
finally who needs impeachment climate
change alarmist Al Gore is saying Trump
should just call it quits my only
message would be resign I mean I don't
mean to be flippant about it I think
everybody knows to discount what this
current administration is doing and
saying they've made the EPA the CP a
coal production agency one you got to
help me out here with this insanity what
is going on with Democrats they're
threatening ice agents I mean you got Al
Gore coming out as if as if anyone's
gonna listen to em you think Trump's
waiting with bated breath to see what Al
Gore has to say Oh Al Gore said to
resign you know what let me just step on
up and do that what are they doing why
not come out with a positive alternative
message I think there are positive
alternative messages where again so much
news these days is national news
especially at our level everybody
follows the national news and the star
of American national news at this point
no surprise to me Donald Trump
everything's about so you're going to
get on the individual message in terms
of specific campaigns that are dire you
will
messages and in fact you see the
Democrats pushing heavy on health care
on the immigration from I can go on but
when it comes to Donald Trump
the reason Donald Trump I think in
today's Washington Post has a 60%
disapproval rating which is a record
high is that he inspires a great deal of
anger in fact fear among people on the
other side of the political art but
people say like you're saying he
inspires anger but then you have these
people on the Left coming out and
comparing him to Osama bin Laden so like
no no that was in terms of his use of
rhetoric and you remember witch-hunt
fake news and I could go on he is he's
pretty good with language and how does
it in a very manipulative way and the
way that he repeats phrases over again I
mean last night in Indiana lock her up
you would think that they were still
running the 2016 campaign
yeah osama's messages no oh my gosh she
was you think about white grievance
today Osama bin Laden was big on
grievance for his guys I think the
rhetoric I mean that's it's across the
spectrum I'm from the Bay Area and I had
someone say to my face that they were
glad that the Las Vegas shooting
happened to country music fans because
maybe then that segment of the
population would appreciate gun control
measures and that that kind of rhetoric
is it let alone from the hypocrisy I
mean it's absolutely aberrant and so I
think you know I'm I'm not excusing that
by any means but I think it's certainly
on all sides and I think Al Gore is the
last person by the way that should be
telling someone to let it go hey Al Gore
give it up Gore V Bush remember that
what about you know mark what's
interesting to me is that you see them
going after Donald Trump right now but
this isn't about Trump then you know if
something if Donald Trump did let's say
he woke up one day and did resign or got
impeached or whatever Mike Pence is
coming on in next I'm gonna take even
more heat I would argue yeah it doesn't
matter you know Bush was Hitler and and
Trump is Osama bin Laden
and you know if Mitt Romney had won he
would be sad and Hassan or Kim jong-un
it doesn't really it doesn't really
matter I mean what I do think is that if
you're going to do this you have to have
a lighter touch I mean that Al Gore joke
of the EPA is now the CPA the cold
production agency that's comedy gold
Gregg will be using me so in fact just
just like forgetting that and just going
straight to the you know Trump is Osama
bin you know and and I like a bit of
this stuff one but it isn't actually the
same Osama and Trump aren't the same I
mean it's not true I mean maybe they
produced Miss Universe for a couple of
years back in the 90s and and Osama said
to Trump hey Miss Zionist entity she's
pretty hot this year and so I don't feel
that they're helpful to your side just
as as political sloganeering it doesn't
work
Gregg does this kind of stuff work where
you you don't you gin up the base and
then you talk about impeachment and yeah
and you equate the president is it
successful is that it may be a
successful strategy for the midterms I
don't know I mean I just remember like
it was in August 2012 Joe Biden told a
diverse crowd that Republicans were
gonna put you all back and change and
now he's you did a fiery speech this
week about civility so I think that
people have a short memory about their
own sins and offenses what I've learned
from this is we're just running out of
evil things to compare Trump to why
don't you just go to the ultimate evil
and compare Donald Trump - Donald Trump
like this Donald Trump is as bad if not
worse than Donald Trump he has actually
turned the media into little church
ladies now Reverend church lady from
Saturday Night Live everything was was
caused by Satan now he's become the
Satan but this is how it works with it
when you when you were comparing
somebody to bin Laden or you're
comparing them to Hitler it's a
flowchart of fascism first you demonize
the leader right you call this figure
Trump you call him Hitler or bin Laden
but then by lot by extension all the
supporters are accessories to evil
that means it's now
okay to call his supporters appeasers
and so on and then what that does that
elevates any action maybe by antiphon as
somewhat heroic because it's a moral act
because these people are evil and then
finally that that encourages violence to
suppress their political freedoms that's
and right now I believe that we're in
between step three and step four we have
seen violence by anti futurus people
trying to suppress their political
freedoms their political voice we're
seeing that happen and this is all but
the first thing you got to do is you got
to demonize you got to demonize and
that's what you're seeing right that's
why the the congressman saying to the
ice if you if you enact Trump's orders
we're gonna come after you that's that
stage whatever it was yeah it's it's
getting there it's getting there and to
your point you have to bring up the fact
that he said what did he say it's overly
overly hyperbolic yeah that was a great
amazing term I have to be precise you
guys remember in the Berkeley protests
recently that there are members of
Antigua that had their faces covered and
Berkeley PD was taking mug shots of
protesters protesters that were arrested
for holding weapons and other violent
acts and they posted the mug shots on
Twitter and then they were called out by
the left for Daxing these protesters and
that's not you don't get to that it's
conflating the protections and it goes
back to what you were saying which is
somehow kind of rendering them heroic
for actually no just breaking the law
and being thugs when it was actually a
First Amendment protected he's breaking
the law you mean if someone is behaving
in a violent aggressive behavior they're
breaking the law yeah but there's a
distinction to be made it's very
important to this conversation which is
that if people are standing up to those
who are fascist and people who are and
hitting them at fight lock racism and
protesting against them
I think the violence is I recall the
violence was perpetrated by the people
you're totally right the distinction is
what you just said where they were
people or cause no that was it was it
was perpetrated by an tyfa and and
protesters who were upset that Trump won
the stuff happened in Portland after the
election those who not Trump people
beating up people so it came from the
left look we
just spent a long period of time listen
to the media saying how harmful Trump's
rhetoric is about the press that it's
gonna gin up violence so this where's
the media on this stuff because this is
actually ginning up rhetoric that could
also lead to violence to just average
Americans who happen to support a
president you know the reality is that
there was a real threat against the
Boston Globe yes you understand that
that's why I'm bringing it up there
didn't come from the left Gregory yeah
but there's acts but the point is that
was a verbal threat there if you look at
the numbers of tape violent cases
against reporters it's gone down this
year and has nothing to do with Trump
people exactly percent let me back this
up going after let me back this up with
the evidence if you look at the
incidences of violence against reporters
it's during protests that quote turned
violent so they either get hit by
rioters or they get hit by anti rioting
Asians like rubber bullets and things
like that see that's why people
reporters at Trump rallies are fearing
for their about these things what's
interesting to me is that folks on the
Left suddenly care about this violence
they suddenly care about extramarital
affairs when it comes to presidents they
suddenly care about character and
leadership and it's really interesting
to see them suddenly awake if you're
going to care about these things then
you should care about violence that's
precipitated on both sides your
character on both sides know there were
people who adamantly defended Bill
Clinton for years also clip that is not
are you talking about storming hey we've
got Facebook Friday coming up because
I'm going to tell you it's about the
potential for an FEC violation